えーただいま
朝の９時ちょっと過ぎたくらいなんですけども！
えー今日をもちまして
私はじめしゃちょー
そして僕の周りの人たち全員で
秋には帰ってくるんだけどね
ちょっとこの夏が
非常に忙しすぎて
ちょっともう本当に
静岡東京の行き来してる暇もない位になってきたんで
本当にちょっとね静岡でゆっくりできる時間もなく
質問コーナーもね
７月の下旬にはやる予定です
って言ってたんですけども
結局ちょっとバタバタしててできなくて
ほんとに申し訳ないです
予定って書いといてよかった
質問コーナに関しては
東京に着いてからちゃんと時間を見つけてやるので
もうしばしお待ちください
ほんとねえ、
できれば静岡にずっとにいたかった
ところではあるんですけれども
やむを得ず東京に行っちゃうみたいな
感じになるんですけど
まあ、すごい不安ですね
この部屋でめちゃくちゃ今まで動画撮ってきたし
ここの居心地が良すぎて拠点を変えたくなかった
っていうのもあって
正直、ずっと静岡
この部屋で動画を撮ってたいんですけど
とりあえず向こうで生活できるように
しなきゃいけないので
ちょっとある程度パソコンとか機材を全部まとめて
今日はお引越しということで
をちょっと動画にしてみようと思います
とりあえずもうすぐメンバーが来るので
それまで僕はちょっと編集をしなきゃいけないので
編集行ってきます
では！
うちの母ちゃんから届いたやつなんですけど
ﾝｱｱｱ！
はじめ：おはようございまーす
ｳｪｲｳｪｲｱｱ
東京行ったら代々木公園とかでさ
フリスビーしたいんだよね
まさき：あー楽しそう
はじめ：ね
ﾈﾔｱｱ！
Fuck you!
ﾊﾊﾊﾊ
たくみ：フッwwwww
はい.皆さんお疲れ様でしたー！
たくみ：イエーイ
長かったねえ
たくみ：長かったわ
東京に着いたんですけども
パソコンとか撮影機材とかを
いろいろこの部屋に今から入れていきます！
たくみ：イエーイ
たくみ：テンション低っ！
wwww
がんばろう！
よし、ラストや、ラスト！
はい！というわけで無事
静岡から東京への
引越しが終わりました
お疲れ様でした！！！お疲れ様でした。
まさき：お疲れ様でーす
一応パソコンの機材も
カメラも服とかも全部
もう完全に東京に移行して
で、まさきは大学院とかあるからね
まさき：うん、向こうで
静岡にいるんですけども
たまに来てくれる感じで
で、たくみは完全にもう東京で
一緒に生活してくれます
というわけで、
これから東京での撮影が
ｺﾞｸｺﾞｸ
増えると思うんですけども
ま、みんなでね、力を合わせて
ｺﾞｸｺﾞｸ
頑張っていければいいなと思っております
ｺﾞｸｺﾞｸｺﾞｸ　ﾌﾊｧｰ
頑張っていくぞ！
全員バラバラにｺﾞｸｺﾞｸ
たくみ：オー！！！
はじめ：オー！！
まさき：おう！
初字幕なので、コメント欄でご意見、ご感想等お聞かせいただけたらうれしいです。
ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟｯ